so it sounds like film festivals are
still very important for you to not only
show the film and you know win awards
and and and have that those laurels
there but meet people and do sort of
again the meet and greet and that that's
part of the following for the next
totally absolutely for me I mean like we
kick-started this film you know and I
raised $20,000 you know and that's from
you know people that I've met along the
way who you know give a damn about me
making another film and like a lot of
that is Film Festival people but I'll
say this as well
I meet filmmakers who I learned from who
become assets to me like you know Paul I
was born in cast me in favor
we met at the first Film Festival I ever
went to for my first movie outside sales
went there met Paul became great friends
now like I'm using his house for this
interview you know I mean like he is a
great asset like Zak Forsman met him you
know at Oklahoma I believe and let's see
his movie and he's been an inspiration
to me and like you learn by surrounding
yourself by talented people who push
each other and and give notes to each
other and like you know I can't tell you
how many really great writers I can just
send my script to and they'll read it
and they'll make it better by telling me
what you know suggestions what they
would do or and that's a huge asset so
also you're building a fan base for you
and your movies which i think is super
important in the indie world because if
you don't have Tom Cruise you know you
have to reach an audience and if people
have a vested interest because they
shook your hand it's just like politics
you know it's like it's harder to vote
against somebody if you've actually
looked them in the eye you know what I
mean
so I like going into places I like
supporting the movie I have the weird
thing about like being worried about my
movie playing when I'm not there
like what's well what if something goes
wrong it's going to go wrong it's a
movie it's technical anyways but yeah I
love the traveling in the film festivals
and I think it's good on many many
levels I think it's great to that you
have a track record a lot of people tap
out after one or two this is not an easy
thing and you don't always make money
back and sometimes there's debt and
there's all these different things a lot
of people are like you know
I'm out this is it I think it's great
that you have this track record and I'm
sure it's not easy but I think that
shows a lot of people that they can
invest in you because you're willing to
show up again sure and like I think
that's true and I think there there's
lots of times where I didn't know if I
was going to be able to make another my
first one outside sales I was so far in
debt when that film finished the
festival circuit I went back to a bar
was working six days a week was broke
didn't have anything didn't have
distribution for the movie it was a
really low time and then I had this
script weathergirl that I sent to the
the lead actress
Trish O'Kelly who had just been in
outside sales as my lead actress and she
read the script and I was asking her for
notes being a man writing a female
character you know I
she's one of my favorite actresses so I
might take a look tell me what you think
and she's like I love this movie I want
to make this movie and I tried to talk
her out of it I'm like no you don't
wanna make a movie I'm telling you like
I'm so far in debt I'm you know and
she's like well I we won't do that but
so we partnered up and we raised the
money to make the movie and like I was
out of the restaurant world again you
know but it's like it's funny it it's
cyclical and it's always a risk and I
love having a I'd say one of the easiest
things about cut to the chase for me was
nobody was challenging my being there
you know I mean and most of your career
as a filmmaker or a writer or an actor
is like convincing people that you are
supposed to be you know like six-month
rule we had on all LA cast in Shreveport
Louisiana and I was the writer director
and star you know and like I felt like I
was proving myself every day not just to
my crew not just to the talent but you
know to everyone you know and so you get
a little ground and people would trust
you and then you know third week was
easy first two weeks was really hard
right this movie there was never that
people were on board from the very
beginning and that's just because of the
track record it's just because they're
like he's done this before I like that
movie we trust him and not having to
gain that faith it just makes everything
so much easier
you